audrey paquet croit encore rêver son
conjoint et elle sont devenus
propriétaires d'un duplex dans cosmo la
petite patrie après une dizaine d'offres
d'achat tout refusé à chaque fois qu'on
fait une offre d'achat on y croit on
fausse devoir habiter leurs cds
remontant investir puis à chaque fois
c'est une grosse déception mais il
fallait trouver le condo familiales
étaient vendus et la famille
s'agrandissait juliette à quatre mois et
sa grande soeur à peine quinze mois
audrey paquet étant très bien malgré
elle dans la spirale de la surenchère
ont été visités par téléphone avec m
agente puis on a mis 100 milles au
dessus dont le popu donc c'est la
chambre de juliette
la famille a finalement acheté une
propriété des mains d'une succession
sans surenchère mais la résidence
nécessite beaucoup de rénovations la
dernière année on a vraiment vu
un changement c'est à dire qu'on avait
le temps de faire les visites
maintenant c'est rendu qu'on fait des
promesses de choses sans faire les
visites le marché immobilier montréalais
est en surchauffe selon ce courtier
immobilier une situation attribuable
entre autres au plein emploi et à
l'économie qui va bien on regarde versus
2018 à 2019 on voit vraiment que
beaucoup de quartiers où il ya des
baisses drastiques de disponibilité de
propriété c'est ce qui cause la
surenchère moins de propriétés
disponibles toujours des acheteurs qui
sont à la recherche donc ça crée un
effet de rareté dans le grand montréal
le prix des propriétés ne cesse
d'augmenter la hausse est de 7% depuis
un an selon les derniers chiffres de
l'association canadienne de l'immeuble
faut vraiment maintenant prévoir que son
budget froid augmenté de 10 15 voire 25%
sa capacité pour arriver à avoir une
chance de déposer 9 la surenchère
atteint même le marché immobilier de la
rive sud
selon cette courte hier le plus en plus
les gens veulent sortir de montréal les
proprios prix des propriétés est plus
intéressant et il ya quand même du
transport en commun
après près d'un an de stress et
d'incertitudes
audrey paquet a bien hâte d'emménager
avec sa petite famille au rez de
chaussée il s'y marier cousineau radio
canada montréal